the media the corporate press lies to
you
about everything they lie about
absolutely
everything no matter what hoax they're
coming up with they love their narrative
you guys know it all
kavanaugh's a serial rapist the
covington kids are racist
jessie smollett was lynched uh
trump is working for russia all the
things that we weren't allowed to
or that we had to say were true under
trump now we're not allowed to talk
about just like
the endless cascade of ridiculousness
well there's this twitter feed called
uh libs of tick tock and they just did a
great job here so what we're gonna show
you is a nine tweet thread
the image that you're gonna see on your
left is what they were saying under
trump
and the image that you're going to see
on the right is the
is what they're now saying under biden
and these are all mainstream news
organizations i'm going to read each
headline and you tell me
if perhaps some of these places of
journalism changed their opinion
because it was their guy in the white
house and now scary orange man was gone
so we'll start with vox
this is june 2020 on the left the effect
of black lives matter protests on
coronavirus cases
explained coronavirus cases are
increasing but black lives matter
protests may not be to blame
here's why huh okay now let's back
let's go to january 21. now biden's in
office
the attack on the capital may have also
been a super spreader event
lawmakers may have been exposed to the
coronavirus
during wednesday's riot okay so when
trump's in office and it's black lives
matter protest no no no no one's getting
covered
biden's in office now covid silver
spreader
wall street journal june 2020
early data showed no uptick in covid19
transmission
from protests public health experts say
preliminary test results are encouraging
outdoor locations and masks may have
helped well that's wonderful
now let's go to january 2021 wall street
journal
at least three lawmakers test positive
after
uh for covet 19 after capital attack
democratic house members sheltered in
room where republicans
refused to wear masks so again
black lives matter protest we're all
good
no more black lives matter protests
protesting over something else we got a
problem
let's go to forbes july 2020
research determines protests did not
cause spike in coronavirus cases here's
forbes
in january 21 lawmakers sheltering
during capital riot may
have been exposed to coronavirus guys
are you getting what's going on here yet
are you are you picking up what i'm
dropping
okay this is some fine work libs at
tiktok very proud of you
uh here's cnn which is a fiction
news network uh june 2020
black lives matter protests have not led
to a spike in coronavirus cases
research says january 2021
cnn 38 capital police officers test
positive for covet 19 after capital
riot my god covid knows your political
leanings and infects you accordingly
it's incredible
usa today june 2020 coronavirus surges
aren't linked to black lives matter
protests
january 2021 usa today
wednesday's storming of the u.s capitol
will likely
be a surge event for the coronavirus
said
dr robert redfield director of the
centers for disease control and
prevention
he told mcclatchy in an interview that
he's worried because thousands of people
did not wear masks
and have since left washington for
various parts of the country
uh well robert redfield if you're
watching this i would love to know did
you
say the same thing when it was black
lives matter protests or didn't you
because people getting together in big
groups regardless of their political
affiliation you'd think the virus would
spread the same way
i'm not a scientifician or a man the
magician just a guy you know
new york times july 2020
did floyd protests lead to a virus surge
here's what we know epidemiologists have
braced for a surge of coronavirus cases
but it has not come yet how convenient
january 2021 new york times
did mixing a riot with the pandemic
yield a super spreader event
members of a mob many unmasked roamed
the halls of
the capital unmasked republicans jammed
into secure rooms the outcome is
worrisome to
many members of congress
and finally the last one just in case
you're slow and you don't get what's
going on here the final one
the associated press which by the way
shares offices with hamas in gaza
uh little evidence that protests
spread coronavirus in the u.s of course
that was july 2020
and in january 2021 possible virus
exposure for lawmakers sheltering during
a riot
we are in an information war
you